[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on challenges of
establishing laboratory developed tests
by dr vijay singh
i'm bill and leicher from thermo fisher
scientific and i'll be moderating
today's event
before we begin i would like to
encourage you to engage with us you can
submit as many questions as you want at
any time you want during the
presentation
simply type your question in the q a box
on the left hand side of your
presentation screen and click submit
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
please welcome vijay
hello everyone uh
today i'll be talking about
our experience here at healthtrack rx um
we are a speciality infectious disease
testing lab right outside dallas
and uh so i'll be talking about our
experience in establishing laboratory
developed tests or ldt's
specifically for disease diagnostics
the presentation today
will be covering in very broad terms uh
the three basic questions that basically
define anything in life the what why and
how
of
establishing an ldt in your lab
so what is an ldt
as the fda defines it now technically an
ldt is not fda approved and is defined
as an in-vitro diagnostic test that is
developed validated and commercialized
for use within a single laboratory
and for anyone who is interested in
developing ldps for use in their lab i
would highly recommend
the website that you see
on the on the slide right now
to visit this website because um it has
some really great information
of what defines an ldp and and how to
get started
so now the question is
why are ldt is needed now very often
and i'll show you some examples later it
is the case that certain diagnostic
tests are not available commercially and
there can be a number of reasons for
that uh maybe it's a rare target that
you're interested in
or the clinical utility
of that particular test is uh not very
well defined
and you know and it is simply not
commercially viable to bring those tests
to market keep in mind that
developing and getting full fda approval
for a single test
you know for the manufacturer it can
cost
upwards of
10 million dollars
uh you know
to to get full fda approved test
and sometimes
some you'll find that the fda approved
test that is available on the market you
know
its performance is inferior as compared
to
some of the other ldt's that are running
and
and the amount of flexibility
that one has in establishing an ldp with
respect to using multiple manufacturers
and sources that will bring together
that test
that
all together may sometimes
makes an ldp both attractive and
necessary
so now
that you have decided to bring the pain
of establishing an ldt into your life
how does one go about doing that and the
very first thing that you do is that you
look for
you know the regulations and the
guidelines that define this process and
this is the very point that it begins to
you know get confusing because you have
all these very different regulating and
guiding authorities that define both the
test characteristics and the laboratory
practices
now within the us uh the ultimate
authority on ldt's is the fda or the
food and drug administration
however what the fda does
is that it
practices
enforcement discretion
and uh
because there are there is clear and
i'll be talking about that in greater
detail in the next few slides and
individual state laws that regulate the
functioning of the labs and the
fda
lets these regulating bodies control the
tests that are being run in the lab
however you know
once you are getting into the process of
developing an ldt what you'll realize is
that
all of these regulating authorities
or guiding authorities
have
certain set guidelines and there is
you'll find there is a major overlap
in
these guidelines and any of the
resources that are provided by these
authorities can be a good starting point
so
here in the us uh it's the clinical
laboratory improvement amendments or
clear
which was established in 1988
that regulates all testing of human
samples in a laboratory
and
these guidelines went underwent
extensive revisions in 2003 which is now
called the
final of the clear final rule
and
it defines the various test performance
characteristics that need to be
established for bringing an ldt on board
but what you should also keep in mind
that depending on where you are located
you have you may have more extensive and
stringent uh local state laws so one
should also keep that in mind while
trying to develop these tests
now
here is very broadly speaking uh the
different test performance
characteristics
that are defined by the 2003 final rule
right we're talking about the reportable
range the analytical
sensitivity and specificity of the test
the
precision of that test on a day-to-day
or over a time period because remember
you can be precisely wrong about
something the accuracy of the test and
the reference intervals now
i'm not going to get into the technical
details as uh these guidelines are
widely and very clearly available
and and that would entail a whole
different presentation
but
the important point that one has to keep
in mind is that according to clear
one has to establish now or be not in
the same great detail but you have to
establish these test performance
characteristics
even for fba approved tests in your
laboratory okay
so what was our experience here at
healthtrack rx in developing some of
these ldt's
it was a somewhere towards the end of
2017 when we launched our large
multiplex syndromic real-time pcr
test panels
that cover a wide variety
of
tests with respect to respiratory
urinary tract sexually transmitted
infections
gastrointestinal and
wound dermatology and ophthalmology
based infections
and
this was our guiding principle
that what we wanted to do was
to develop a testing strategy that
incorporated a multiplexed real-time
pcr-based syndromic panel approach
that saved both time and money
again for both the patients
and their providers
that ultimately results
in better clinical decisions with
respect to patient care
so in brief
the idea was to provide the maximum
amount of clinically relevant
information to both the patient and the
provider
and to do so
at a reasonable cost again to the
patient
and
to us
at a reasonable cost and profit margin
so to anyone who's thinking about
establishing ldt's in your lab
right the first thing that you should do
is that you should you need to determine
a testing strategy
that works best for you
not only as a scientific exercise and
i'll be you know
going into some details on that you know
again not just as a scientific exercise
but as a business decision also
and uh it is not just the test or the
assay alone
that has to be the focus it is the whole
workflow
within the lab
that feeds into that test that needs to
be streamlined
in such a manner that the wastage of
time money and resources is minimized
and the information that is generated
for both the provider and the patient is
maximized
and
again i'll be bringing up this point
again and again is that
as you begin to think about developing
these strategies these workflows or
bringing these tests on board right
you would want to work very closely with
your asset manufacturer or your test
developers
right
so
what was our approach
when we looked at the whole
workflow right here is an example
of our
respiratory
infection panel or the rpp panel
and
when you look at these targets
i can tell you
with a very high degree of confidence
that if you go about looking for
fda approved tests on these
there are maybe one or two
non-viral targets that are fda approved
and depending on the manufacturer that
you may want to work with
you may have
anywhere from two to six or maybe seven
viral targets
that are
that have fda approved tests available
and uh
when you looked at the very extensive
list of antibiotic resistance markers
that we have
only two
of those targets are really reimbursed
by the players
right
if you would
go about looking for
again fda approved or clear wave test
such an extensive list is simply not
available
however
what we have seen in a number of cases
you know there is a
huge amount of clinically relevant
information
with respect to you know the pathogens
or the infections that might be present
in a patient sample that would simply be
missed
by
a lot of these uh
point of care test or fda approved tests
and uh
we published a paper in 2019 detailing
you know the severe limitation of uh
some of these point-of-care tests up to
50 of the time where clinically relevant
infections would be missed
by some of these tests and so that
in itself um
validated
our approach
towards developing the ldt's
and uh
to talk about the workflow as i said
everything else that flows
into that assay is also equally
important so uh
we spent a significant amount of time
and resources in
developing a lysis and transport medium
and
i can say that we've sort of achieved
true synergy
wherein we use this single medium for
all our different sample types so
whether it's rpp sti wound gi whatever
the sample type may be we use this
single
uh
medium for transport and that allows for
uh you know in transit lysis also
and again like i said as a business
decision when we looked at developing
the ldt's what we realized that you know
that running these extensive panels
would make sense at a certain
patient volume or sample volume
and for that
it became very very apparent very soon
is that we would need automation at
different levels of the workflow and one
of that point which was proving to be a
big bottleneck was the extraction of the
nucleic acid from the sample so we spent
again a significant amount of time
in uh
developing automated processes for the
extraction
and which is once we have the nucleic
acid in hand we follow it up with
reverse transcription pre-amplification
of the samples because we found or what
we
ultimately went with was a nanofluidic
real-time pcr based platform
which allowed for really high throughput
uh
performance of the pci
and then followed by the that real-time
pc that i was talking about ultimately
leading to the report which is the
product
that we put out for the providers and
the patient
again we have streamlined this workflow
which again minimizes
any wastage with respect to time and
resources for all our different sample
types
okay
looking at you know some of the
examples with respect to the performance
characteristics
and herein i would emphasize the point
of working closely with your
asset manufacturers
is that one of the biggest
you know stumbling blocks that labs face
in
in developing any extensive panels
is finding the reference material of
you know
when you use that reference material to
establish some of those test
characteristics and it can be very very
difficult to find true relevant
reference material so the manufacturer
that we work with was able to provide us
in a timely fashion you know
all of our target sequences
at a defined known value
what that allowed us to do was to
establish the limit of detection of our
assays and to basically
uh do good dilution assays that allowed
us to
look at you know
a good linear correlation for all of our
assay targets so you can see
what we received was 10 raised to power
5
copies of our target sequences which we
could very quickly do a good
dilution assay and see very very good
sensitivity for the test
and in the meantime we kept working with
the
a lot of sources so public health
departments hospitals clinics
in
sourcing
true known patient samples
with the clearly identified infections
and uh some of the relevant examples are
here and you can see that we could
establish very good linear correlation
for all of our assays and that allowed
us
to
you know
define a lot of our
test characteristics that are laid down
by the different guidelines whether they
be from clear cap
or iso or the fda
and
now
you know i'll be talking about uh a more
you know
timely example which was the
establishing of a code 19 test here at
uh healthtrack rx
and uh
it was uh somewhere
in february of 2020
when uh the covert 19
was declared as a public health
emergency and as a pandemic
and so we moved very fast now keep in
mind that our experience was more with
these multiplexed large panels and we
never uh
till this point we haven't really done
any
single target single pathogen type pcr
tests in the lab
and but we moved fairly quickly
in trying to establish this test
and
when we started generating data for this
test in the lab
the emergency use authorization that was
given by the fda
was very limited it was only for a
particular extraction type
it was only on a particular machine the
abi 7500 which we did not have in the
lab
and uh so what the fda suggested was
that if you wanted to do anything else
they defined it as a bridging study
because they had laid down the the test
guidelines of the characteristics or the
performance characteristics of
these tests
and
so we started with the
defining
all the various different sample types
you know again the
automated rna extraction
and the real-time
pcr performance on
machines that were frankly different
and we didn't have any resources at that
moment of getting any of those machines
in the lab and frankly we'd not have the
time to validate those new machines okay
and then the assay
was also different
from what was approved at that point
uh and again you know the different data
points and different test
characteristics were established so here
is our whole table for the limit of
detection and you can see that it was uh
established at uh
10 raised to power one copies of the
viral target per microliter
and it's not that we could not
detect it at any lower values if you
would go that we went right down to 10
raised to power 0.1 copies per
microliter
of our
target however
we made a decision of uh
tapping our the limit of our test
at 35 ct values because if you look at
the linear equations even though this
is a great
uh linear
correlation for the different assays or
the different targets
uh you can see
that you know if you look at the
equations themselves the moment you
start getting beyond
the 35 ct value
uh
you the
the clear determination
of whether the sample is positive or
negative
would become questionable
and then
we had
all of our samples from the 2019 study
saved in a deep freezer
and
that allowed us to do
a good specificity study when you know
all the other syndromic targets
we found that there was uh
no interference
from those
and uh
overall the specificity of uh
testing a difficult uh
sample type like the sputum samples as
opposed to
a nasal or an oropharyngeal swab
uh put together the predictive value of
our test both positive and negative was
found to be hundred percent and then at
the same time we move very quickly to
do interlab correlations
and uh you know
for uh
as per fda guidelines we took the
difficult sample type which was the
sputum and
we correlated our results with
another lab
and that allowed us
you know for the granting of our
eua and uh since that time i would say
in the last
18 months or so
we have performed
nearly 2 million covert tests
and so why i gave this particular
example was that when we were generating
this data with respect to filing for the
eua application we were also
following
all the guidelines
from
with respect to a capricorn you know
inspection and uh the idea was that all
the technical repetitions all the
biological repetitions all the precision
studies the accuracy studies that are
needed that we had all of that data on
files for our cap inspection and when
our
cap inspection window opened in february
of this year
we passed it with flying colors because
we already had that data
and
you know for people who may find it
difficult and again
yes we were coming from a place of high
experience but at the same time this was
a new approach for us but all of this
work you know
if one thinks that it is difficult yes
it is however if you are planning and uh
as i used to say in a previous life to
all of my students that one month on the
bench will save you two hours in the
library
you know
it's an excruciating amount of planning
that goes into it
but all of this work with respect to
establishing the covert assay
was done in a period of 10 days
so with that
i'll uh summarize this presentation
that yes establishing an ldt can be a
very daunting task and if you look at
the different regulating bodies
and keeping in mind that you may have
you know
a particular state laws also governing
you
this can be very very confusing however
if you look at those
guidelines in a very broad sense these
are the basic principles of good
laboratory practice that are guiding you
so follow those guidelines and follow
those guidelines to a t keeping in mind
that you will have to pass an inspection
right and if you're doing that
again there can be limitations with
respect to resources
and uh what your testing strategy has to
be what your business strategy is right
you will have to make those decisions
however
the decision of establishing an ldt
in the lab should always keep the
patient interest
at its core right what is the clinical
utility of the test
how will that test
impact the patient life how will that
test provide all the clinically relevant
information to the provider to
to make the best decisions with respect
to the patient's care right that has to
be kept in mind right but after that
right
what you should always do you know you
have to remember
that this ultimately is is a business
decision okay
so you will have to bring all of that
together and the workflow in the lab
and uh the costs of running that test
and what would be the reimbursements all
of those different things have to come
together for you to make that decision
and again i cannot emphasize this enough
if you ask nicely and work closely with
the manufacturers of those assays
it can be a very easy task because like
i said before you may be resource
limited but realizes that people and
collaborators around you
will have
expertise that you may not possess at
that time and they will help you
bring together these ldt's that you know
to the market
to your patients to your providers
and it can be you know
a task that that is easier than it looks
uh and uh with that i would like to
thank uh
the whole infectious disease team here
at healthtrack rx
uh
again i'm privileged to work with the
such a great group of people
uh in the last one and a half years with
the pandemic
uh i have i've
i've never seen again a more committed
group of people they've been through
hell and back and i i see them very
tired all the time but uh you know
never wavering in their commitment to
the patients into the turnaround time
and i would like to thank all of you for
listening and i'll take any questions
that you may have thank you
thank you vijay for sharing your
personal experiences and
reflections of what it takes for a
clinical lab to bring a in-house
molecular test to market
we have received some great questions
already
vijay what advice would you give to a
laboratory looking to implement its
first ldt
again
great points to emphasize again
you know
the the first and the foremost
that they should look for again like i
said there are some great fda approved
tests available right
and uh
they have to see they have to keep in
mind that
what is the niche that they are
targeting you know
is it uh
clinics is it uh long-term care
facilities hospitals
or uh
you know
opd population and once you have that
clarity
and you know what sort of sample volume
you would be looking at
and then
what the market needs are where the gaps
are and they would want they want to
fulfill those gaps
then they need to define
the the testing strategy that would go
and again
it has to be with the realization that
you know some of
the time and the resource
that needs to be put into developing
these leds can be fairly extensive it
can be it can be expensive
for a lot of labs
so
first clearly define the need that you
want to fulfill and then
look at the resources that are available
to you
and again collaborate like i said one of
the
one of the big stumbling blocks in
defining the test characteristics is
finding the resource or the reference
material you know so work with the
public health departments in your area
work with hospitals you know connect
with the universities around you
and the clinics around you
and
like i said work very closely with your
asset developers if you're not doing it
in-house
and uh you know
all of those resources coming together
all of those expertise besides your own
coming together
will
will make this whole exercise easier
great we have a two-part question it
reads do you have any tips for someone
who is new or unfamiliar with panel
development and testing and are there
any resources you find particularly
helpful
so like i said if that has to be
you know
extensive planning and i can talk from
uh
from our own experience here is that
you need one
you know you can do a survey of the
clinicians around you
and uh
they will tell you what sort of tests
they are interested in
uh
do a extensive literature search
the idea with us was to
bring together you know a very high
percentile
of the pathogens representing each
syndrome
and then obviously at the same time we
did a market survey of the clinicians
around us
and uh you know
they pointed out certain targets that
were not a part of our original list but
we found that there was enough interest
in
the clinicians
for
for those particular tests or for those
particular pathogens for each panel type
and
again
i say this with the full realization
that you know
not all laboratories are going to have
those resources at their disposal or
they may not have the time or the money
to
to invest into that however
i would still very seriously suggest for
everyone to try and take that approach
because
in the long term
that would allow you to put a good
product out in the market
for the like i said i keep saying again
again for both the patient and the
provider
and
then how you design your workflow will
allow you to to do it at a at a price
point
that would again
maximize
the information
and minimize the cost
vijay how quickly are you able to change
your panel content and bring a new test
to offer to your clients
so the nature of
our large multiplex panels
the way they are engineered and the way
the technology is
uh it takes
anywhere from four to eight weeks if we
have to make extensive changes on our
panels
however you know depending on uh
i'll give you an example what we
realized with our sdi
panels was
that a large number
of the providers were
interested in gonorrhea chlamydia and
trichomonas test only
and
so
what we did was that we created a small
panel specifically for that
and we basically took it out of our
took these three targets out of our uh
large multiplex panel
and uh
again you know i think we'd already cut
our teeth with the covert assay and uh
if
you know from the standpoint of
manufacturing
uh
it took less than three weeks to do that
what uh what would you say is the single
most important thing to keep in mind
when developing a successful test
personally i would say that you need to
look at the
the clinical utility of that test
and uh
you know always keeping the
the patient's interest at heart
but
not losing you know
the
the perspective that yes it is a
business decision also
so one should uh
one has to bring in different aspects
there
is no one
true
fact or aspect that defines
the ldt
uh and
so you you will have to keep in mind
that is there
you know
a gap
in what is available to the patients
is there a certain market need
and again if you do decide to bring that
on board
you know what would be the implications
of running that test
uh with respect to
fair reimbursement
and even if those reimbursements are low
can you design a workflow that will
minimize your cost and would allow you
depending on the sample volume would
allow you to perform that test and can
you bring that or can you commercialize
that test within a reasonable profit
margin so all of those aspects
truly come together and so i wouldn't
say that there is one true aspect that
that is overarching and defines it
we we do have time for one more question
uh vijay what are the most
time-consuming or challenging parts of
the process for bringing a test to
market do you have any advice
so uh like i said uh
one of the uh you know it's the actual
planning of the assay itself
and uh
you know
once you have identified the system that
you want to work with
and uh
then
you know there are certain areas that
are
are more clearly defined like i would
say in the whole process the
nucleic acid extraction process
that's that's more well defined there
are certain known ways that in which you
do it and
you may have experience with one system
versus the other
and those are
easier still
however
the design of the panel itself
you know
and then uh depending on who your
manufacturer is
that can take a long amount of time
and
uh then
once you
once you have the asses in-house once
you have them in your hand
the
the thing that can take a long amount
a bigger amount of time
is finding the proper reference material
so i would suggest that one should start
looking for the certified reference
material whether it's through
you know
a known source like atcc which can give
you
the
the pathogens themselves
and
you can spike
the proper matrix
and do those tests
or if you work with the
synthetic pieces of dna
or you work with you know hospitals or
public health departments that can
provide you with those samples
or work closely with the universities in
your area
that will let me have some research
material available to them but that is
one aspect that takes
a
a long time
to bring together
and then again it's it's the planning of
those experiments so read those
guidelines carefully and they very very
clearly define
the
the basic minimum criteria of doing each
experiment
and what are the
repetitions and what sort of statistics
needs to be done on that data they
clearly define those so make sure that
your planning of those experiments is
done
you know
beforehand again follow those good
laboratory practices
and
it'll be a much much much easier task
thank you vijay that is all the time we
have for today as a reminder to our
audience
questions we did not have time for today
and those that are submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed via
the email address you provided at the
time of registration
so thank you again to our speaker vijay
singh and to everyone who participated
in this presentation we hope you enjoy
the rest of the event and please be sure
to check back frequently for new content
and presentations added throughout the
year
you